- My ability to fool other people.
Cause it's a game, right?
You're playing a game and
everyone's trying to be someone
and the better you can
pretend to be someone,
is as good as a it'll
ever look to someone else.
I don't know who I am in the end of it.
Which is interesting 'cause I don't know,
you know, you expect to be
a certain kind of person,
you think you're a certain kind of person,
and when you don't know,
then you're confused,
and you're messing yourself.
- I'm a drug addict, like straight up.
Like, I'm sober now, but I've been,
I've struggled with drugs in the past
and I, you know, like I work on it,
but it's something that
really scares me about myself.
'Cause I know how
self-destructive I can be
and I know that like, if I don't keep
on working on this problem I have,
then eventually I will
just like self-destruct
and possibly kill myself, so.
- My anger, my anger scares me.
- [Interviewer] Can you give us an example
of a time where your anger scared you.
Yeah, like I found out my
boyfriend was cheating on me
and I was afraid I might kill the girl.
- [Interviewer] You were what?
- I was afraid I might kill her.
Not like murder.
That scared me, you know?
- The thing that scares me
about myself is how easily
and fast I get attached to things
and ideas of things and
ideas of people slash people.
Let's say, let's say you
start talking to somebody,
as soon as you start talking to somebody
and they give you the most
little bit of attention,
boom, I'm attached.
Come here, let's talk more,
let's hang out, like literally.
Same with friends too like
second I meet somebody,
if we match energies, boom.
We're connected.
You're now part of me, kind of situation.
- I guess that like your upbringing
and experiences and everything negative
that happens to you
defines you as a person.
And I forget that I'm 1000% judged
on what I've done in the past
and my wrongdoings, my shortcomings.
So I would say being defined by
the things that make me vulnerable.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Is this
something you think about often?
- Oh, probably every day.
Yeah, I think I struggle
with opening up, yeah.
- My future.
That's what I would say.
I don't have any like future plans.
I don't really know myself too well
so I don't really have anything
to look forward to, I guess.
- What scares me the most about myself
is that I can do anything that I want.
Like I'm the luckiest
person alive, I think.
I would love to do a lot of simple things
and then I'd like do a
lot of complicated things.
I would love to be a chemist.
I'd love to be an environmental engineer.
I'd love to learn about algae and oysters.
I love to be a leaf.
I'd like to be a tree.
I'd like to be an elephant.
Anyway, yeah.
- [Interviewer] So the
fact that you could,
in your mind, you could
be any of these things
and you can't decide,
that's what scares you most?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I'm scared to decide.
- I find it really hard to focus.
Probably like every three
months I shift gears
and this is my thing now.
And then it lasts three months.
Right now it's sailing.
- [Interviewer] Sailing?
- Sailing.
Yeah, I just bought a boat in
Mexico for not enough money.
It's a really boat.
- [Interviewer] How long ago
did you get into sailing?
- About three months ago.
(both laughing)
- [Interviewer] You
have me thinking though,
like why do we feel like we
have to stick with one thing
our whole life like
why not do what you do?
- Because I'm a really saver
and I'm not a particularly
good anything else either.
But I know a little bit about a lot of
it's not very useful to anybody though.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- I'm scared that deep
down I think that I know
I won't do what I want to do with my life
and I think that's what scares me most.
I don't know, maybe I've
been told that by a lot
of people that I won't make it
and that I'm not good enough.
- I'm not scared anymore.
I used to be scared but
I'm not scared anymore.
That's my answer.
- I think I have trouble figuring out
when to be guilty and when not to be
and when it should make
sense and when it shouldn't.
I often get a lot of guilt put on me
and I handle it weirdly.
I just feel like I'm blamed for stuff
more than I should sometimes.
And so, I don't know if
I need to work on myself
or if I shouldn't take the
blame as much, I guess.
- I feel like I'm
stressed out all the time
and like my brain kind of goes
at like a million miles a minute
and like I can never really turn it off.
And I think that I worry
that I'll never like
know like a full peace with myself
and like be able to just
sit down with myself
and like feel good being silent
and like alone and like not feel the need
to be doing a million things at once
or like anxious about everything.
- [Interviewer] Have you ever felt peace?
- I don't know.
- As much as we want to believe
that we know ourselves
more than anybody else,
there is so much unpredictability,
infinitely, actually.
We are not the same person two seconds ago
that we are two seconds later.
Without our permission.
And I think that's what scares me.
- I feel like every day
I'm a different person
and every day I have a
different set of morals
and things that I know
are true about myself.
But the next day I'll think about
the decisions I've made the previous day
and I'll realize that that's not who I am.
But I really don't know if it
is who I am or if it isn't.
Because I think like,
when I'm doing something
I'm doing it mostly just
based on like what feels right
because I've been told that
that's like the way to live.
But what feels right is not
always good for everyone.
And I think what I'm most
scared about myself is
how I harm people without knowing
and how that affects not just them
but another person that they know
and another person that they know
and ultimately like the world.
And just not realizing
the weight of my actions.
Even the smallest actions.
And I guess overall not
having self-control.
Yeah, that is really, it's really scary
and it's really hard and I
don't really have anything
that I feel like I'm loyal to.
Like I don't have a set of
morals that I'm loyal to.
And because I like grew up like atheist
and so I know most people like,
it's just a part of their existence
to have like certain beliefs
and for me it's very ambiguous
and like there are many possibilities.
And I think that's why it's so
hard for me to center myself
and really see what is
true to me and what isn't.
And so I think the only
way that I can learn
is through experience
and a lot of mistakes
and a lot of damage,
which I don't want to do
but I have no other way of learning, so.
Yeah.
- When I know that I want something
and I don't just do everything for it.
- [Interviewer] Why is that your answer?
Is this something you've
been thinking about?
- A lot, yeah.
I recently like met a stranger
who gave me this long speech
about like if you know
your passion go for it
and if you don't go for
it you're gonna regret it
for the rest of your life.
And I literally had just
decided I'm gonna give up on it
and the potential to not chase what I know
that I want is really scary.
- [Interviewer] Where'd
you meet the stranger?
- I was on a flight and I got moved
actually to randomly sit next to him
and it was just an old guy
and he just started talking
and it was just a divine intervention.
I'm an artist and I wanna be a musician
and I had just like, I'm a sociology major
and I had just decided to like hunker down
and just like give up and stuff like,
doing the thing that I love
and the thing that I wake up
and think about every second of my life.
And then, I was talking
to him and he was like,
"Why would you not?"
- [Interviewer] Yeah, why would you not?
- Because I'm never gonna
be the best in the room
but I'm also never gonna
be the worst in the room.
And I let myself like be scared of people
who are better than me
rather than be inspired
by people who are better than me.
And I don't know, it's just
something I need to stop doing
and I just need to focus
on doing the thing.
- [Interviewer] Where
can you find your reason?
- Oh my.
I, nowhere I, my bedroom.
Sorry.
- [Interviewer] It's okay.
- Hi everyone.
I have an exciting announcement.
I'm working on a book of secrets.
So if you have a secret that you would
be okay with me including in the book,
please submit it by going to
the link in my description
or by going to Thoraya.com
and hitting the Leave A Secret tab.
I have it set up to where
you will be submitting
the secret completely anonymously.
Please only share a secret
if you are 100% okay
with me sharing it in the book
and all my other platforms.
I'm hoping you'll be able to pre-order
the book by mid-November
and that I'll have them
shipped out in time for the holidays.
So keep an eye out for that.
I'll let you guys know once
it's ready either on here
or on one of my other platforms.
And that's about it.
Thank you guys for everything.
I love you all and I'll see you next week.